Cómo podemos comprender mejor el terreno
al pasar el cursor con el fantasma de la
edificación notamos que la animación da
pequeños saltos Esto se debe a que el
juego se divide en secciones cada una de
estas cuadrículas puede estar despejada
u obstruida esta característica nos
ayuda a proyectar y así obtener una
mejor percepción de las zonas ocupadas y
de las que no lo están esto nos permite
dejar liberada una zona que necesitamos
para que los aldeanos puedan recolectar
o para obstruir un peligroso hueco en la
muralla y evitar que el ejército rival
se inf
en zonas con inclinaciones la
visualización se complica aún más ya que
es fácil confundirse con las animaciones
de las estructuras Por ello es vital el
uso de las cuadrículas para detectar que
algo aquí no cuadra podemos activarlas
en opciones interfaz red y elegir Si
queremos que estén siempre activadas
También tenemos la opción de seleccionar
el color y su
intensidad